[Musique]
sous l'oeil des caméras et des riverains
un à un les corps sorte de la terre et
de l'oubli 6000 burundais au total
enseveli par d'autres burundais comme
cet homme prisonnier en 1972 il a dû
obéir aux ordres et enterrer les morts
ici tout au long de ma chip 6 partout
c'est moi avec ces prisonniers qui a lui
enterré là bas vers nkunda quand tu
traverses le pont il y a un petit chemin
qui monte vers guy iata il y a deux
fosses communes là bas j étais au moins
depuis son indépendance en 1962 les
massacres déchire le pays
conflit censé avoir pris fin le 4
décembre 2008 avec les accords de cessez
le feu entre gouvernement et dernier
groupe rebelle conflit que la commission
vérité et réconciliation lancée en 2014
doit mettre en lumière au dixième jour
de nos travaux nous inversions les
victimes étaient majoritairement dit lui
même ethnie mais parfois il y en avait
d'autres qui périssaient à la suite des
conflits elle terre personnel militaire
prêtres enseignants des enfants même et
si la commission ne précise pas l'ethnie
des victimes hutu tutsi ou carussi c'est
que le sujet est hautement sensible
le pouvoir actuel la majorité hutu a
diligenté ses travaux pour établir la
vérité sur les massacres à ce jour 140
mille tués ou portés disparus ont été
identifiés
il reste plusieurs milliers de fausses
communes à fouiller sur l'ensemble du
territoire d'ici au 20 mai 2020
prochaine élection présidentielle
durant ce délai les violations des
droits de l'homme pourrait encore
augmenter a prévenu l'onu